we just got some new iOS 17 leaks from
the most reliable Apple leaker out there
finally giving us Clarity on if we
should even expect any worthwhile
features and changes so in this video
we're gonna dig deep into what we should
expect to see from IOS 17 as well as my
own personal wish list of features that
I think would not only be awesome to
have on my iPhone but ones that are
actually realistic in terms of being
implemented by Apple so let's get
started now you probably know that iOS
16.4 has finally been released with a
bunch of new features which I'm gonna
get into later in this video but we're
gonna Focus first on iOS 17 which is
going to be officially revealed in June
at Apple's WWDC event now getting into
that huge iOS 17 leak it's actually
coming from Mark German Chief
correspondent at Bloomberg he said that
Apple was initially thinking of calling
iOS 17 a tune-up release where they
focus us more on fixing bugs and
improving performance than adding new
features now the reason for that was
because iOS 16 was an ambitious update
with a lot of changes and new features
but the problem was that it was very
buggy and still is to this day however
later on in the development process they
decided to change the strategy and bring
some new nice to have features to iOS 17
even if it lacks big improvements like
what we got last year so the goal of the
new iOS 17 software codenamed Dawn is to
basically bring several of the most
requested features from Apple users to
iOS finally now before I get into what
that could be I want to point out that
ironically there are a lot of people on
Twitter and on Apple Focus forums like
Mac Rumors who would actually prefer a
tune-up software update to fix all of
the bugs that we currently have and they
prefer that over a bunch of new flashy
features that look and sound cool but
aren't very useful in the real world
they just want it to work reliably
without all these bucks and in case you
don't really know what issues and bugs
are still happening to this day here are
a few examples of weird glitches and
problems that people are having and have
actually experienced some of these as
well including text being overlaid over
other texts and trying to swipe but not
going back to the home screen that
actually happened to me as well and it
was very very annoying now to be honest
my point of view is that these bugs
should have been fixed by now and they
should always get fixed within the same
OS year instead of relying and hoping on
a full iOS release to fix bugs now of
course iOS 16.4 just came out with new
features and changes like new Emoji
Safari web push notification voice
isolation for calls order tracking
widget with purchases using Apple pay
new changes to podcasts which are nice
and of course a bunch of other bug fixes
but now let's move on to what we should
expect from IOS 17 which will include
several of the most requested features
from Apple users so I'm gonna get into
some of the ones I saw online that I
think makes sense for Apple to implement
the first one is adding a pause video
button because right now your only
choice is to stop the video wait a
little bit and start a brand new video
so if you're at some kind of event or
some kind of race or something else and
you're trying to record and you wish you
could pause you can't you end up with a
bunch of separate clips that you have to
go in and edit them together if you want
a full video of something happening
here's another one I saw today which was
actually very interesting it's a why are
you calling feature sure so basically
when you call somebody you can type in a
little message and then when someone
receives the call they'll get that
message saying hey I'm calling about
this or I want to talk about this that
way they see the call they know what to
expect and that could avoid some people
just kind of ignoring calls because they
don't know what's happening they don't
have time that's a really cool idea and
I feel like apple could definitely
Implement something like that it would
definitely be new another one that I see
online is the calculator app which
absolutely sucks so many people complain
about it and it stayed the same for so
many years it is so incredibly limited
and another big one that I saw online
that makes a ton of sense is adding
features to the dynamic Island because
we've had it for a few months on the 14
pro and pro Max and it's still a little
bit limited and seeing as the new iPhone
15 models coming later this year are
also getting rid of the Notch and
getting that Dynamic Island I think it
makes sense for Apple to finally start
adding more and more features and make
it more and more useful so I definitely
think apple is adding that later this
year with iOS 17. another one I saw
which actually annoys me is that right
now you can't separate the ringtone and
alarm volume sliders it adjusts at the
same time with the volume buttons Apple
needs to allow you to change them
separately which would be so useful so
you don't have issues with ringtones and
alarms being crazy loud or whatever else
and another one that I completely agree
with is adding numbers to the top row of
the keyboard on iOS 17 because whenever
I test another Android phone and that
phone comes with a full row of numbers
without having to hit the whole number
button get up to it it is just so
convenient compared to Apple's solution
so I wish Apple would add that as well
and now let's get into my own personal
wishlist of the features that I really
really want Apple to add with iOS 17 and
the upcoming iPhone 15 Pro and regular
models the first one is for the Pro
Models out there and that's to do with
the 48 megapixel sensor which forces you
to use Pro raw I wish Apple would just
allow you to shoot in heif or jpeg right
on your iPhone and they definitely
should be able to do that because you
can use the shortcuts app to convert any
pro raw photo into heif you can even set
it up to happen automatically but Apple
it just doesn't allow you to do it so I
wish later on this year they will unlock
that feature and that way we can all
save a good amount of storage space on
our iPhones now this next one has to do
with the iPhone 15 pro model because we
did get some leaked cads of the design
changes and from what we know right now
the iPhone 15 Pro is getting rid of the
mute switch that we've had for 16 years
and replacing it with a new mute button
but to me it seems like apple is
actually adding an action button like
what we have on the Apple watch Ultra so
in that case I'm hoping that apple is
going to release some software updates
that will help better utilize that
action button now I don't know if it's
coming right when Apple announces iOS 17
or if it's waiting until the iPhone 15
Pro launched but I think Apple's gonna
release some softer features that have
to do with what you can do with that
action button now another good option
that I saw on Twitter was that the
action button could actually be a focus
mode cycle button where you click it and
you can cycle between your focus modes
automatically with a push of a button
without having to actually open it up go
to the control center nice and easy and
then you can press and hold for the
actual mute switch functionality I think
that could make a whole lot of sense now
with that said what are your most
requested iOS 17 features let me know
down in the comment section below and
hopefully you enjoy this video if you
did go ahead and click the circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one definitely check out one of those
two right over there including the
potential April event leaks video
definitely watch that so thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign